اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم استمرار التوتر عند الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه حزب الله استهدف موقعا عسكريا
اسرائيليا في مستوطنه المناره كما شيع
عددا من مقاتليه الذين سقطوا على الحدود
في حين قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي مناطق جنوبي
لبنان ونشر مزيدا من التعزيزات العسكريه
على الحدود الشماليه مع تواصل الغارات
الاسرائيليه على غزه عدد الشهداء يرتفع
الى ثلاثه
18800 ووزاره الصحه تقول ان الاعداد تحت
الانقاض تفوق ما يتم نشره بكثير في حين
خرجت اربعه مستشفيات عن الخدمه ولحقت
اضرار ب 25 وسط تحذيرات من انهيار وشيك
للقطاع الصحي مباحثات بين رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ونظيره الاسرائيلي في القدس
سوناك اكد دعم بريطانيا لاسرائيل ورحب
بقرار فتح الطريق لادخال المساعدات الى
غزه بينما قال نتنياهو ان الحرب ستكون
طويله في حين حذرت روسيا من مخاطر جديه
لتحول النزاع الى صراع اقليمي سبعه شهداء
برصاص الاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه ما يرفع
العدد الاجمالي منذ بدء الحرب على غزه الى
69 ياتي ذلك مع حمله اعتقالات واسعه تشنها
قوات الاحتلال في مناطق الضفه الغربيه
شملت اكثر من 120 فلسطينيا الى
اللقاء
ه